hello you're not it's daniel
bravo that's done you can breathe
here are four things to know for the
follow-up number to your results
these are available online 13
days after the exam not counting the
day of the exam  exam that is to say that
if you pass it on Saturday 1st your
results are available on Friday
14 then more 13 14 and this deadline is not
compressible
as far as the certificate is concerned it is
sent by mail the same day that the
results are  available
so it can take more or less
time if you go fast and in the
berry where are we going if you want to
pick up your certificate at our
premises in paris you will have to notify us
72 hours before we send it
number 2 communicate your results once
school or university to the news
it is possible it is enough for it to
fill a small online form
available on our site
we can send up to 5
free and only to
universities and institutes  official tions
by mr inside everything +1 point number 3
corrected your results
it's possible just fill out a
form with lots of people
available online it will have
to be done within six weeks of
hand shine and you will find the price and  the
terms on your site
number four
despite my great video you still
have questions it's possible yes
always contact us on iphone os 4
0 point fr and don't hesitate to
leave us an opinion on facebook or google
that's it  for me I hope
you will have the expected results she
follows me